Einem forschungsteam ist es jetzt gelungen zum ersten. Mal das menschliche gehirn mit dem internet zu verbinden, und zwar in echtzeit
und dauerhaft und in zukunft sondern dann auch wirklich daten auf unser gehirn übertragbar sein auch wir dann überhaupt
Noch interfaces wie smartphones. Und computer und was passiert. Dann wenn wir mit dem ganzen wissen verbunden sind das erfahrt
ihr jetzt paar klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es klingt nach science fiction chor aber forschungsteams und unternehmen weltweit tüfteln mit hochdruck
Daran, das menschliche gehirn direkt mit computern. Und vor allem auch mit dem internet zu verbinden
Nicht nur facebook ist da dran sondern auch der unternehmer ihren
Mast mit seiner firma neuerer link über die haben wir ja vor kurzem heftig zum science fiction ausführlicher berichtet in seinen
vorstellungen können wir in einigen jahrzehnten elektronische
Geräte direkt mit unserem gehirn verbinden. Und zwar mit hilfe implantierter
Chips im hirn die bits. Und bytes in gedanken über setzen können
und umgekehrt
Auf facebook hat ähnliche pläne menschen sollen demnächst direkt aus dem gehirn heraus worte im computer schreiben lassen
100 worte pro minute seien das ziel eine textnachricht zu schicken. Ohne. Dabei das smartphone
aus der tasche zu holen das hatte facebook im vergangenen jahr auf der entwicklerkonferenz f8 in
Kalifornien bekannt gegeben das unternehmen beruft sich auf forschung an der stanford university
Bei denen, eine gelähmte frau acht worte pro minute in den computer
Eingeben kann bohlen große elektroden im gehirn erkennen die. Aktivität der neuronen wenn
Sie, einen bestimmten buchstaben tippen wollen das forschungsteam von facebook sei nun
Dabei, sehr empfindliche sensoren zu entwickeln die die aktivitäten im gehirn sehr genau verfolgen können
So wäre es dann auch nicht mehr notwendig die. Einzelnen buchstaben im kopf zu bilden was zu dem auch dazu führen
Können dass wir bald auch. Andere. Sprachen sprechen können. Und zwar. Ohne sie vorher
Zu lernen der gedanke an ein behälter in der hand aus dem man flüssigkeit trinken. Kann könnte
dann
direkt mit dem entsprechenden fremdwort für
Tasse auf japanisch oder englisch umgesetzt werden was bereits. Heute schon funktioniert ist die kommunikation zwischen
Zwei menschen die hirnströme über das internet austauschen dies ist ein forschungsteam aus washington schon vor drei
Jahren, gelungen da habe auch. Darüber berichtet der ist proband mit einer die kappe auf dem
Kopf bekam alle möglichen dinge auf einem bildschirm gezeigt zum beispiel tiere oder gebäude der zweite. Proband saß in einem
Anderen, raum und sollte herausfinden welche dinge seine mitstreiter gerade gezeigt worden waren dazu
Konnte, er fragen stellen indem, er das betreffende bild mit einem cursor berührt
Dabei, seinen kollegen blinken dadurch zwei lampen in unterschiedlicher frequenz eines für die antwort ja eines für ein
proband 1 musste dann nur noch das richtige licht anschauen
Dann, wurden seine gehirnströme in ein digitales signal übersetzt. Und über das internet an den fragesteller rüber geschickt
Und der dann wiederum seine haube aktivierte. So wurde ein magnetfeld in seinem sehzentrum in der großhirnrinde
stimuliert und er sei nicht
Wenn die antwort ja lautete auch wenn es kein echtes licht war doch für seine neuronen ja macht das keinen unterschied die
trefferquote des experiments lag bei 72
Schon ziemlich wahnsinnig. Ein weiteres projekt menschliche gehirne mit dem internet
Zu verbinden hat jetzt vor kurzem erste erfolgs ergebnisse geliefert. Ein
Forschungsteam aus johannesburg hat die elektrischen impulse des gewinns per livestream an eine website übertragen also in echtzeit
Und ständig also auch unterwegs das ganze nennt sich brain internet
funktioniert so die testpersonen tragen ein gerät das, ein, eeg
Aufzeichnet also die elektrische. Aktivität des gehirns und diese dann grafisch
Darstellt die idee signale werden an einen raspberry pi computer weitergeleitet der sie wiederum an eine programmierschnittstelle
übergibt durch die verwendung eines codes ist es dem programm möglich mit anderen programmen zu kommunizieren
Und so konnten die daten an eine webseite weitergeleitet werden zusammengefasst wurden hier also
menschliche gehirn aktivitäten über ein technisches medium an das internet übertragen und in echtzeit
Und dauerhaft und es geht noch weiter denn die beteiligten forschern behaupten sogar dass in naher zukunft das auch
Andersrum funktionieren wird das also daten und informationen voll an computer ins menschliche gehirn übertragen werden
Teils dies alles funktioniert ja wird es die welt wie wir sie
Kennen, komplett umkrempeln anstatt eine e mail zu tippen würde es ausreichend einfach kurz an den gewünschten inhalt
Zu denken der computer verwandelt unsere gedanken dann in entsprechenden text zudem hätten wir zugriff auf gedanken und erfahrungen anderer menschen
So könnten wir also problemlos die erfahrung von anderen erleben zb die eines promis oder eines soldaten
Auch wenn wir bestimmt das fachwissen haben wollen, müssen wir nur an den wunschdenken. Und könnten schon die gedanken entsprechender expertinnen und experten
herunterladen doch natürlich gibt es auch hier wieder mögliche negative oder sogar fatale folgen denn wer garantiert uns
Dann, dass gedanken nicht einfach wahllos gelesen werden bzw
Mit anderen geteilt werden klingt alles nach
Science-fiction pur und viel experte und experten zweifeln noch an der umsetzbarkeit dieser vision den sechs supercomputer sind jetzt hat lediglich in der lage
Wenige sekunden die aktivitäten des menschlichen gehirns aufzuzeichnen fest steht jedenfalls noch, einen schritt weiter
Und schon sind wir bei einer der drei visionen des sogenannten transform annis muss der digitale neue mensch auch
Upload bezeichnet diese vision ist ziemlich radikal denn demnach wird das bewusstsein des menschen durch eine vollständige digitalisierung
transformiert der name dieses prozesses hohe
Brain relations oder auch ab loading das gehirn wird hier also quasi als austauschbare hardware definiert mensch
Und maschine haben, sich. Dann. So angenähert dass eine digitale
Kopie von personen möglich ist eben wie ein download der identität unsere jeweilige
Gehirn software kann. Dann auf avatare überspielt werden ja also das ist noch zukunftsmusik aber das andere
das hat schon stattgefunden das werden
Also erhebliche fortschritte erzielt und die daten zwischen hirn und internet werden immer genauer übertragen einerseits ja andererseits
ein, bisschen spooky können dann gehirn in zukunft gehackt werden
Und was passiert wenn gehirne mit künstlicher intelligenz verknüpft werden da gibt es eine menge technischer
Aber auch moralischer fragen wenn, er keine videos zum vernetzen werden. Und zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Dann, umgeht er die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube. Und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp der von mir. Noch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video täglich garantiert einfach draufklicken. Und am besten auch
Meine schwester kammer klicks, um, social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür ihr klicken aber nicht die
Die bob vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit darf auch draufklicken
Künstliche intelligenz entwickelt sich immer schneller bis dahin
bleibt dran